hey guys i'm chris kohler and i am tired
game developers conference this year
it's pretty much wiped me out i was
running myself ragged playing wee bit i
was playing a real guitar that works
with a new pc game that's coming up and
there's plenty of stuff for me to do
down here but um GDC this year is it's
been definitely a lot more subdued than
in previous years it's not the year of
huge announcement to Big Apple Microsoft
use their keynote to announce gears of
war two but it's not like it's playable
on the show floor and if it was just a
trailer the other keynote this year was
from break hurts while who's not even in
the video games industry I mean that's
great you know TVC doesn't need to be
like a little III packed with game demos
and things like that it's a place to get
business done its place to get deals
done most importantly this year it's a
place for indie game developers to get
out and get their faces in front of in
front of some of the big publishers this
year the independent games festival
pavilion where a lot of the award
winners for showing stuff off is packed
with people they've got stacks and
stacks of business cards these kids
these young kids who've made these games
and and their you know their future
looks pretty bright I'll tell you for
some of the award winners and so it has
been the year of the indie game
microsoft sony nintendo all announcing
or furthering their programs to get
independent games on their consoles but
the big games the smash brothers in the
wheat bits and the gears of war they're
here but they're the presence isn't as
big as it once was but all in all I
think this year's GDC is exactly what it
needs to be is a great place to get
business done that's what happens
you